paul van noy back on the books for the
new england patriots cut by the dolphins
wasn't happy about it
lands in new england just the latest guy
uh-oh that the patriots are rounding up
as they try to improve that roster and
get back on the the right side of being
relevant to what's happening in the nfl
no i mean awesome i mean he's their kind
of guy certainly you know they just the
dolphins outspend the patriots last year
they weren't willing to spend 15 million
a year on kyle van noy now they get them
for something they look at more
reasonable but he's the perfect patriot
guy you know again can play defensive
end inside linebacker outside linebacker
you got judon kyle van noy dion you know
dante hightower coming back off of the
covet opt out all of that you know it's
a different defense already we know the
secondary's top notch is as good as it
gets in football and now you start to
look at the front seven on paper and you
start to go damn that's a pretty good
front seven i mean watch out so a great
move by the patriots and and good for
kyle benoit getting back with the team
that he's familiar with
this one was a stunner last night
patrick
signed by the minnesota vikings
top 10 pick back in 2011.
uh hey the vikings have
had issues at corner ever since
uh you know it
every one of their guys left last year
in free agency world was cut they went
with young guys now they have an older
presence
my understanding is the teams that were
interested in patrick peterson want him
strictly to play corner not slide over
to safety and we don't know what's going
to happen with anthony harris in
minnesota he's currently a free agent
but there hasn't been any news about
anthony harris that i've noticed but uh
peterson now becomes uh the top corner
on the depth chart just by virtue of the
fact that they're they're struggling to
develop great cornerback play in in
minnesota and we know how important that
is to the defense and i don't know i
don't know what kind of gas p peterson
has left in the tank ten years in but uh
one year it's been reported this is one
of those that you gotta watch right one
year 10 million
i would bet not quite 10 million
but ten dollars
that it's up to 10 million not 10
million right when we see the final
paperwork but still i bet it's about 6
million and he can make 4 million on top
of it if he plays really well it's a
significant investment for a guy's been
around 10 years chris and it shows the
vikings are doing what they can to
improve defensively no doubt i mean you
know again i i don't ever love the ped
part of patrick peterson's past you know
that we've discussed that um but you
know everything else he doesn't really
miss games he's not hurt a whole lot and
he he loves football there's no denying
that i mean there's not and
not that he's a superstar lockdown
corner anymore no he's not that type of
football player but there's there's
still good left in his game mike there
definitely is you know last year we saw
some past interference issues things
like that but i think it is a good
veteran presence a dependable guy
smart knows that you got a rookie corner
that they drafted in the first round
last year right so you know it is a
position that's very important to
zimmer's zimmer's defense and uh i think
patrick peterson does help them out
another move that happened on
wednesday and another
2011 first round pick aj green
signing with the cardinals one year deal
worth up to eight and a half million
dollars uh and and look chris my first
reaction when i saw this larry
fitzgerald's not coming back and i know
people are saying oh larry fitzgerald
love to play with j.j watt and aj green
look at the depth chart de'andre hopkins
christian kirk aj green where does larry
fitzgerald fit is he going to be is he
going to be a gunner on the punt team
yeah where does he fit because when you
have now i guess some teams can get away
with having four guys
who play receiver and don't play special
teams but financially where does he fit
yeah that's right how can you give how
can you give him the aj green deal when
you're paying deandre hopkins top of the
market you've got these other
commitments i i just think that they did
the aj green deal and maybe maybe larry
fitzgerald did the cardinals a favor by
keeping his mouth shut about what his
intentions were because it allowed the
cardinals to go get aj green and not
have to worry about someone else
grabbing it yeah maybe you're right
you're right you know
there's no doubt they could have played
that aj green is a guy i'm very
intrigued with it was a down year last
year there's no doubt he never really
got the connection going with joe burrow
or anything like that
i do still think i mean again this is a
tall guy with size
but like when i watch him on there's
still explosion in his game to where you
know i wouldn't be surprised if he
opened eyes again a little bit in this
offense where yeah he's gonna see a lot
of single coverage but man you talk
about dan arnold the tight end who
emerged last year really damn good
hopkins you said it christian kirk in
the slot and doing that stuff and then
aj green outside that's that's some
tough matchups across the board i think
aj green still got a little something i
bet you he comes back with a little chip
on his shoulder this year
last year was so bizarre now the year
before it he suffered the ankle injury
after the preseason practice in dayton
because it was the league 100 season and
he didn't play at all in that year they
franchise tagged him in 2020. he had 104
targets but only 47 catches it was weird
an average yards per target of 5.0 by
far the lowest of his career the bengals
clearly weren't bringing him back
typically the bengals once they
franchise tag you in your playoff that
year you don't come back right um and an
eight and a half million top end it
shows you the league right now is is
curious about where aj green is and he's
gonna have to re-establish himself and
this is his chance to do it he's been
around a while he's had
he hasn't had a thousand yard season
since 2017 and he barely hit a thousand
yards that year uh he's got some work to
do to establish himself again but it's
not like he's going to be double covered
it's not like he's going to be the focal
point of the defensive game planning no
he's going to step into the larry
fitzgerald role and you know chris
what's your gut tell you
if
if it's gerald dunn or do we see him
maybe
exploring the possibility of jumping on
a super bowl bandwagon because he said
at one point last year
the cardinals win the super bowl i
retired everybody's like well then
you're not retiring was that his
little sprinkling of the message that
yeah maybe next year i'll go join a team
that i think can win a super bowl i i
don't think so my gut tells me that you
know he's sitting back if he comes back
i think it will still be with the
cardinals for like a really low price to
where he just wants to be a part of the
team i don't know but i i really my gut
and i have no knowledge of this
situation
i do think it's done i do um and i would
expect maybe we hear something here
sometime in the near future but the aj
green things you know it's intriguing
and that stat you talked about with the
targets right that was one thing that
when i you go back and watch a little
bit you go well
he was open a little bit more than i
gave him credit for watching the
watching them last year you know joe
burrow just it was one of those weird
things where they could not connect on
go ro go routes and back shoulder type
things where you go wait aj green's open
joe burrow you know threw it out of
bounds or under threw it a little bit
there was a lot of disconnect there um
but but it's interesting and then hey
listen i i just got to mention the other
move with the the cardinals too them
getting rodney hudson damn that was good
i mean you know we thought the raiders
were going to trade them i mean dr cut
them to for the cardinals to get him
that that's that's very important
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports